pays sont de plus en plus
nombreux à se rendre en Roumanie
- Le Danube, célèbre fleuve
européen devenu une sortie de
secours du conflit ukrainien.
our, ils sont des
centaines à braver le froid
et traverser le cours d'eau.
Comme aux autres points
de passade passade passade passt
des femmes et des enfants
qui descendent du bateau.
(en anglais)
Natalia s'inquiète
pour ses grands-parents,
restés dans la région d'Odessa.
À bord du traversier, elle a
retrouvé par hasard son amie
Julia, marquée par les bruits
des bombes et des sirènes.
"Quand on entend un bruit,
on se demande ce q
se produire", dit-elle.
Cette Ukrainienne aimerait bien
trouver refuge auprès de proches
au Canada, mais n'a pas encore
décidé si elle s'y rendra. rend.
Pour de nombreux réfugiés,
la Roumanie n'est qu'une escale
dans un long voyage.
- Il y en a, ils ont prévu
des plans, ils ont des amis
qui viennent les chercher,
de la famille qui vient
les chercher. Et il y en a,
ils y vont, ils ont fui,
ils ont pris leur bagages.
Ils y vont étape par étape,
ils savent pas trop. Il y a
vraiment tous les profils.
- Mais tous savent ce
qu'ils laissent derrière eux.
Plusieurs de ces réfugiés
viennent de la région d'Odessa.
La ville portuaire a été
relativement épargnée jusqu'à
présent, mais les autorités
sont en alerte et craignent
des bombardements.
L'attaque sur un hôpital
pour enfants de Marioupol,
à l'est du pays, est un triste
rappel que cette menace
est bel et bien réelle.
Tout comme les combats
à Mykolayv, à 130 km d'Odessa.
C'est dans cette région que
se trouvait la femme de Bill,
un Torontois qui s
jusqu'à la frontière roumaine.
(en anglais)
"Ma femme était effrayée, sans
eau, nourriture ou électricité",
dit cet homme qui est ici depuis
six jours. Dans l'attente, il a
décidé d'aider les réfugiés.
Sa femme a finalement réussi
à atteindre la frontière.
Après des heures d'attente,
fausse alerte :
pas sur ce traversier;
il faudra encore patienter.
(en anglais)
Une fois réunie, le couple
restera quelque temps en
Roumanie, pour participer
aux efforts de bénévolat,avant r
pour la destination finale :
le Canada.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,